[Music]
all right you guys uh know will smith
was married
before jada right right did you have a
son that's 47 years old he did have this
on before i didn't know
i didn't know he was married until as a
reason within like five years
because a son came out that was [ __ ]
47 years old so he's opening up about
his first marriage right in 1993 he
started a movie called six degrees of
separation and he says that during that
he had just gotten married to his wife
shri at the time and they had just had a
kid
right named trey
and at that point he was filming this
movie with his co-star stockard channing
and he says he fell in love with her
while he was married he was married he's
a ladies man huh he can't keep his
[ __ ] mind together well that was 93
he was hella young right that's him in
93 with starker channing that looks like
michael jackson i know she yeah maybe
michael jackson was going for that look
maybe maybe he's going for a little bit
of stalker channing look did you ever
see that cause you're not like nicki axe
and stuff like if i should have to get
booked a big role cause sometimes i get
word for myself like let's say i have a
super hot co-star yeah and i fall for
her or something because you're a method
actor you have to continuously do the
kissing scene and you see it all the
time and you gotta practice at home over
and over are you saying i gotta [ __ ]
start i'm gonna i gotta leave right now
i gotta go home okay i gotta see what
she's doing oh they say i gotta leave
just a jerk off i gotta go jerk i gotta
go jerk to think about my wife and
another man
bye guys that's where your head goes did
you ever like was she ever worried are
you ever worried uh no
never gil have you ever had a situation
where your your co-star was a lover of
yours no
dude a monk a month after i got married
to nikki she had to kiss a dude in this
movie that i wrote called funny story oh
yeah that see that was i was like how
did you deal with that i cried on set
and then you asked her for a hug after
you're stronger than me no i sat there
like this the whole because they're
actually filming it right and i said and
then i stepped in and i went oh i can't
believe you're doing this to me how
could you do this to me
[Laughter]
baby
i took it like a man
did he tell you
now she's taking care of rant
and then he looked over at me and he's
like no that's how a real man does it
and i was you know and he's all
meanwhile he's like yeah i just bought
bitcoin [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm making life changing money [ __ ]
you see this a lot right like you see
brad pitt with jennifer addison and then
after mr and mrs smith it was
him and angelina the most famous one i
think they get so in the character that
they just fall for and if you're
shooting overseas you know you guys are
rehearsing lines you guys might be in
the same hotel you're spending so much
intensive time together for like six
months didn't he also do that with that
one chick an allied oh yeah the french
chick yeah the french [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah i mean isn't it bound to happen
because like you're playing that role
and then you're
you know you're just in it and you're in
love as the character but then it kind
of becomes a piece of who you are your
body doesn't know that you're just
[ __ ] acting but the hormones and [ __ ]
are real and then you fall for them
that's what he says he says that he
basically um you know his wife at the
time married a guy named will smith but
he felt like he was being his character
at home even and so he was like
missing stockard channing because he was
like feeling for her on the set it's
like this weird cross mix and then they
had an impaired so you know but there's
also some scumbag dudes that will use
this excuse to be like baby you don't
know i got a lot of love there's some
character
is it the performing arts center dude
[Laughter]
well he
yeah wasn't he still in his 20s at this
time 93 yeah
you know he's actually still one of the
the cleaner ones compared to how far he
went with his journey at his age and
stuff like that you know what i mean
like
yesterday we were talking about mike
tyson
wait what'd you guys say
and we were talking about brad pitt
actually with mike tyson's [ __ ] wife
you know what i'm saying who was all
fresh prince so it's kind of she was
right oh yeah she was so it's kind of
like uh for will to
i mean this just sounds like oh okay
that makes sense will was probably
crushing everybody that's what i'm
saying everybody on french prince he had
a [ __ ] uh did he yeah dude he had
[ __ ] tyra banks was on there oh yeah
do you think he [ __ ] her banks that's
what i'm saying if anything maybe he
just
he's one of the cleaner ones like this
is a confession when he's like i fell in
love with my co-star it's not like he
banged her in the back of the [ __ ] rv
you probably did though he says he
banged her in the ass
that's what he said oh god there's a
video play it
you know what i'm saying like in a weird
way compared to mike tyson yes he's
clean like but but even we're all clean
compared to mike tyson compared to most
of them he's still pretty cool even brad
pitt right a lot of people would like be
like oh i don't watch brad pitt's movies
anymore because you know he cheated on
jennifer aniston and it's like a whole
thing i watched a [ __ ] ton of them still
not me that's not me i love that so many
good movies i watch more after i think
the moral is
don't commit if you want more tits say
it one more time
don't commit if you want more tits
hold your microphone
don't commit if you want
let us all right five person riding team
for this the jokes are gonna be really
scattered but it's gonna be right i
can't wait for the for the 50-minute
mark when we all look at each other go
this was a horrible idea
we take our names off the posters yeah
why this is really like long
racist we bring back the uh the bart
going over the marvel cinematic universe
bit
that was more wholesome this is just
racism
why did we get so many cameras for this
oh man this is this all this came out
with his new uh autobiography right so
yeah he has a new book out and this is
part of juicing that but that's what i'm
saying like i'm surprised he didn't
cheat more that's that's what i'm saying
think about will smith's juice like will
smith's juice over the last couple years
is jada cheating on him and telling
everyone on facebook about it he's a
[ __ ] dude his image his public image is
a [ __ ] cuck but it's probably why
it's so successful too though like oprah
just [ __ ] gave him like mad profs on
this book you know when the whole jada
thing happened was he dating other
chicks at the time like i don't
understand what the whole thing was they
were open relationship no that's why i
mean from what i saw i thought they were
open though that's what everyone said
they were like kind of open but like she
had gotten entangled oh that's because
it was a notorious open hollywood
relationship right but it was supposed
to be no strings attached but then she
felt something is that the difference
more like it was great content for their
show
yeah red talk killed it with ads what is
this was it uh the guy she cheated with
wasn't his name like august or something
yeah august august mcgregor
[Laughter]
you guys ever wonder what mike lowry
would think of will smith no please tell
us what he thinks
we need we need to know well no mike
lowry is will smith's character in bad
boys movies so like wouldn't he think he
will miss a little bit of a [ __ ] now
yeah probably yeah
you don't think you don't think will
smith was like [ __ ] other chicks
during that time i think he was for sure
i bet he was it's hard to resist that
kind of [ __ ] right well especially for
him he's will smith he's coming out in
the 90s but i guess the real bit today
bro he's crushing i'm sure but the real
question is how horny is will smith
because i have a few friends who are not
horny at all and there are many women
that probably throw themselves at them
but they're just not horny who's not
horny undisclosed people very unhoarded
say their name do they say do they tell
you how unhorny they are they they
confide in you they call you up joe
i'm so not everyone's hitting me up and
trying to [ __ ] me and i just can't do
this i'm just not horny enough because i
want to [ __ ] you
can you sit down and i need to tell you
a secret i'm not really horny at all i
made that call on my own
horny level so what is what are the red
flags of your friends where you're like
these fools aren't horny well one
they um
they obsess over romance right so
they're more they're more feelys peoples
right they like committed relationships
so they don't like [ __ ] around which
is good you're talking about me i'm not
horny no no but but you're horny man
you're a horny bastard you talk about
sex thank you i think the final element
is they don't talk about sex they're not
they don't get excited when they when
the subject comes around and they just
feel unaffected they could be private
about it too oh that's very true it
could be guilty people are guilty yeah
they have catholic guilt i do have a
friend
in asia
where we were hanging out enjoying life
and he said you know what i think i'm
done having sex oh wow yeah he says i'm
done
was he like 93 or he says i got it out
of my system no and
we were in our early 20s he says i got
it out of my system still talk to him
now no i call this bluff after that i
was like [ __ ] this guy i think he has
soft hands is what happens he says i'm
i'm i'm done he goes and i'm ready to
settle down i'm like dude we're like 23.
he's probably murdering people today he
says he's he's uninterested you probably
want to have sex even after you get
married oh yeah i mean i mean like just
[ __ ] lots of chicks every day yeah
that's different i think
yeah like a a a a heavy libido is what
i'm saying it's different from like what
if will smith he does [ __ ] maybe he
[ __ ] around but maybe it's like really
really small compared to like i don't
know like someone like dennis robin i i
think he's [ __ ] like everyone yeah
everybody men women
he'll [ __ ] a bush if you want you know
that's what i'm saying is george w yeah
there's george w bush
i just googled w
[ __ ]
i just googled this will smith [ __ ]
and it says it talks about how he and
jade [ __ ] other people even though
they're married yeah it's open right
yeah i feel like that's why i don't
understand the whole entanglement thing
why he was so offended by that that's
why i just that's what i'm saying was he
uh was he offended but he was like she
was like we had entanglement he's like
oh that's what you call it so i'm like
aren't you guys an open relationship
that is a funny ass word yeah
entanglement is wild bro just say i was
in a relationship with another guy or is
it just like another episode in the show
to make it a really good show no way
dude
that's real they had a real conversation
there's no way it was produced oh guys
[ __ ] sure i cannot could you i am a
fan of will smith and when i
when i when i watched it or uh you know
had seen it and stuff like that i was
like dude this like sucks for will so
they did a great job whatever the
[ __ ] storytelling but it didn't make
me like lose any like love for him as a
person and made me admire him you
actually got way more points
he won in that situation that episode
with jada pinkett smith was the same
level of will smith when he found out
his dad never came back and he was like
[ __ ] on his dad the whole time well
he loved me man to uncle phil that one
god damn that same level bro
the red table one didn't make me cry
that's for sure i cried you cried listen
to what i for him
yeah dude i cried for him he was crying
i felt bad for him why was he crying
because his wife's [ __ ] other dudes
he got a guy named august i was laughing
at him dude
oh like look at this [ __ ] can't even
[ __ ] hold down his own marriage i
don't think he was punk ass [ __ ] dude
mike lowry would shut up
hear that will smith joe thinks you're
pumping out stephen hiller would [ __ ]
shrug like he'd be like not just just
kidding he's he's way more successful
than i am
we're big fans we're a big fan no dude i
give him props
could you be in an open relationship
[ __ ] no dude [ __ ] no i can't do it uh
probably not now maybe later on we've
talked about it i can you didn't ask me
well i know you can what about you steve
joe's like i would love to monkey eat my
butt i'm like
you know
talk about open relationships no money
in my butt my butt no we're asking would
you be
here
steve would you be able to never [ __ ]
know i could never oh no no she can't
[ __ ] no other guys [ __ ] no girl eat all
the monkey butt you want
everything else but man
no man allowed
monkey buttons
[Laughter]
[Music]
you